[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh that's not the case with this guy the
more we find out about him the more
valuable he is
he's tim calishaw dallas morning news
columnist and star of espn's around the
horn
if i talked to you yesterday yes what
would you have said about what the
cowboys were going to do with dak
prescott
uh i gave it in the morning a 10 chance
they would do anything other than just
franchise him today
so i i was i was off by 90 i suppose
on where this thing was headed but i
talked to a couple people who covered
the team on a daily basis
they were they were a little higher than
that they were 15 to 20. so
there wasn't a lot of thought this was
going to get done was yesterday a good
day for the cowboys
that shouldn't be an easier question to
answer yes i'm going to say
yes uh but it's not a great day for the
cowboys
it's a great day for number four yeah
it's a real good day for him
um you know i i just think there's
realistic concerns
these numbers are real that the teams
are not winning
or going to super bowls with
quarterbacks making 35 to 40 million
i mean tom brady wins most of them but
even if you took out the ones he's won
recently the quarterbacks
that would have won the game would have
been goff in his first contract or
or you know mahomes again and so it's
the guys it just gets really hard to
build a roster it's not impossible
but it's tough they have they have a
green light for this year
they have a 22 million dollar salary cap
figure for dak
this year that that's good uh that's
going to go up quickly
and and and you know and then in three
four years they're back at it again with
it so this is kind of a one-year window
okay do something in 2021.
my question is not about you know dak as
much as it is that defense
unless their philosophy is we're just
going to outscore people
because that defense has been an
embarrassment
i i think the philosophy between those
two i think they're hoping
they're hoping dan quinn by coming here
you know brings the seattle defense from
seven years ago
with him not the crappy defense he had
in atlanta
as a head coach most of the time um
but that but that's a coaching change
they need they need personnel they need
pass rushers
they're going to have to draft quarters
they know that
so again they're they're they're kind of
doing
what they did after dak and zeke's
rookie when they went 13-3 and they
rebuilt the secondary
they got rid of brandon carr and all the
veterans and said we're going to draft
woozier and jordan lewis and these guys
and and so you're
you're counting on that the defense has
to help you can't win
you can't you can't just sit here and
say we're going to score 33 points a
game
that that that's not realistic
i was also wondering about this you know
dak is coming off a broken ankle
yes people don't like to talk about that
no
but i do i like i i watch the video tim
it's real um he didn't get
hurt at the bargaining table with a
broken ank coming back from a broken
ankle
and that and that's shocking to me and
i've written about that a number of
times
you try to put it in a nice way as
possible but realistically
this guy was he was five rushing
touchdowns a year
he was a threat to run he's more like uh
you mentioned deshaun watson a minute
ago he's more like that as a runner
he's not kyler murray uh or lamar but
but he but he was a threat
and he also because he's big he would
try to run over defensive backs a little
bit
and now having experienced what he did
with logan ryan
is he going to back off from that is he
not is he strictly a guy who's in the
pocket
uh and how does that how does that
change his value to the team
nobody has that answer i also wondered
about this you've written about this but
if jerry had signed dak prescott two
years ago
he would have got it in a bargain i
think but then would they be
in a similar situation in a year
where dak would be signing up for even
more money
with this new tv deal and that he would
be ready to go
you know back on the market well if
they'd assigned him two years ago i
think they would have
the extension would have lasted as long
as this one
does they would have redone the last
year of his rookie deal
and stuff so at some point yeah he's
going to be
if he's a successful quarterback he's
still going to have some prime years
left
clearly when this when this contract
runs out
so they've got four years they got four
more years of it
and and and they got to do something at
that point that's nine years that's nine
years for zeke
that's that's a lifetime for a running
back so
they've got a you know you were just
talking about quarterbacks the other
starters in their division are daniel
jones
jalen hurts and i guess taylor heineke
at the moment
i mean you know dak is beyond head and
shoulders above that group
they got to make that channel they got
to do something with that they can't
keep wasting these years
are the cowboys in a super bowl over the
next four years
no i'll say they're going to end their
nfc championship throughout
25 years without one they'll get to that
in the next four years but if i'm
sitting here making a prediction today
there's a lot that has to go right with
this team
and this coaching staff and this head
coach
uh to get to a super bowl that they're
they're in better position by being in
the nfc
looking ahead than the afc almost all
the good young quarterbacks
other than kyla murray are in the afc
and that's where it's going to be a dog
fight
to get past my homes and everybody for
years they're a little better fit
there but there's there's still too many
good teams
green bay's got years left lord knows
tampa bay's got years left
with their quarterback so i i would
they have a chance but i would predict
no is dak prescott a great quarterback
he's a really good quarterback uh i i
i would say no i'd say he can be
but i would say also year six
is he likely to suddenly get better i
don't think so but
what we saw the first five weeks last
year surrounded by really good talent
uh he could he could lead the league in
passing
yards and and and win
bigger playoff games than he has
but he you don't look at him like you
did aaron rodgers
10 years ago or russell wilson after
four years and say this guy's great you
say this guy's good
you gotta keep him you gotta put people
around him
and let's see what happens he hasn't
proven greatness yet
if you could get one get rid of one
contract
on the cowboys right now which one would
you get rid of
i would get rid of jalen smith's and
although that's not that bad a contract
i think he
counts 10 million this year
um they're they're okay
right now that they i think they've
always
three of their top five contracts are
offensive line the top six contracts are
offensive
linemen and uh and that's hard
to do to put that much money there and
not put any in the defense
and here i am taking a defensive
contract away
i just think linebacker being the
position it is
uh that's the one i would probably
remove i don't think they have any
terrible
deals i wouldn't take away demarcus
lawrence just because his sack totals
are down i think
he's still an important player but they
have got to
have a great draft which they're pretty
good at and and they've got to
somehow make this defense middle of the
road
do you feel bad that we won't be talking
again for a few years
well we have luca
danny what's there to talk about
he's pretty good that that's another
team that needs to build around
a guy who's pretty good except he's more
than pretty good um
it is a little sad uh writing at least
one
contract column a month has been kind of
a kind of a toss-up
for two years uh because there's it's
always gone these different
different directions and and like you
said the cowboys could have done
themselves a big favor
and i i still think of stephen jones
saying two years ago we're not going to
set the market
great great plan we'll just have a
market
and we're going to give a guy 40 million
and now people are mad here
because he got too much money yeah were
you secretly rooting for russell wilson
to come to the cowboys
i i didn't spend more than despite your
intrepid reporting which got this whole
thing started
uh i didn't really spend more than five
minutes on that i
think seattle would be insane to trade
him i
would have been would have been
different um
and uh but no i didn't i didn't really
ponder that as much as i
could have yeah that's that's good
that's smart on your part
uh uh tim thanks for joining us as
always and uh we'll look forward to your
next appearance on around the horn
that's today today's dac day oh
so if i can't win today yes yeah i mean
what am i
what am i doing here wow you're right
about that
uh well we'll be uh we'll be rooting for
you tim as always
what's a good facetime i wonder i
haven't even thought of that my gosh
oh you're already thinking about winning
not usually at 8 30 in the morning
thank you tim tim kalashaw he's calling
his shot and you know tony reality is
watching right now going
oh calishaw calling his shot on the dan
patrick show earlier